[MUSIC PLAYING]
ALEXIS COX: Hey, Carl.
CARL KRAUSS: Hey.
ALEXIS COX: Thanks for taking
me through your demo today.
CARL KRAUSS: Yeah, of course.
ALEXIS COX: Can you tell me a
little bit about what this is
and how it works?
CARL KRAUSS: Sure.
This is a 3D representation
of the architecture diagram
for the industrial asset
maintenance with Google Cloud
IoT and AR.
This is an app that shows
an industrial device
that we have overlaid
augmented reality on top of it.
And so what this is, it allows
you to see sensors inside
of this.
And this device
connects into IoT Core.
So I'll show you a quick
demo of how this works.
And so you can see, in
here, we have sensors.
And I can trigger
a fault. And you
can see that that fault is
directed back into IoT Core.
And you can see it live,
realtime on this display.
ALEXIS COX: Cool.
Can you tell me a little bit
about the technology that's
going on behind the scenes here?
CARL KRAUSS: Sure.
So inside of here, there is
some sensors that are securely
connecting to IoT Core.
And they're using
public/private keys,
using MKGT that are connecting,
and sending data into IoT Core.
And IoT Core is a
secure device registry.
It's a service that Google Cloud
offers for connecting things
like this asset that we showed
earlier, but could potentially
connect hundreds of
thousands of devices.
And so now we have IoT Core.
Now all of these things
can be configured.
And data can be sent
through to Cloud Pub/Sub.
So Pub/Sub is a public
subscriber messaging queue
that allows data to be
buffered in a large bucket,
and for subscribers to
come through, and pull
that data off, and do some
sort of translation on it.
So as we walk down here,
we'll see that messages
are put onto a topic.
And they're duplicated
for different subscribers.
There's kind of two
different things
that you can do after Pub/Sub.
So first we have
Cloud Functions.
And Cloud Functions is for
maybe more simple tasks,
like taking an event, unpacking
it, and then maybe writing it
to a database.
Cloud Dataflow could be used
for maybe a little bit more
complex, maybe ETL jobs.
And so in this
example, we're doing--
taking the last five
pieces of sensor data,
averaging them together, and
then writing that to Firebase.
And the reason
we're using Firebase
is for that realtime aspect
on those mobile devices.
And so when that AR overlay
is laid on top of that device,
the sensor data is realtime.
So if you see a fault that
we talked about earlier,
you can see that realtime.
And a technician may be able
to debug or troubleshoot that
using this technology.
ALEXIS COX: That's really cool.
Thank you so much
for the walkthrough.
CARL KRAUSS: Yeah, no problem.
[MUSIC PLAYING]